welcome to this video playing white here
in this five-minute game against so cool
so cool from the UK probably get a
modern defense yeah modern dance yeah
this is some relatively popular line on
club level it's not very good to be
honest black loses lots of time with his
night ended does not really have any
particular benefit um yeah I have played
this myself as black years ago um let's
say 15 years ago 20 years ago but um I
really came to the conclusion that it's
not very very good that's not like
losing or anything but it's just
strategically speaking very risky
opening as you lose this much time yeah
speaking of strategically risky f5 is
also quite risky weakening on the whole
position especially the e-file and e6 e7
um okay he I don't know what he wants to
do book to g6 on um well I'm just going
to put pressure on them under the iphone
let's see how to how to play this the
trip here on f2 is not really doing much
I wonder where should where should place
it I have an entirely different idea
here the Queen here is helping to put
pressure on f5 the night will come over
to g3 and i will have bishop t to see 3
yeah i think this is a good setup
get get this Bishop on g7 may be
exchanged yeah b5 this it's nothing
serious and just play be 30 is allowing
night to h5 that's that's funny now
maybe you couldn't prevent it but it
looks it looks quite quite crazy to
allowed an idea um so should I play rook
every and and stuff immediately look f3
g3 why not yet and bishops though to see
three check em
he goes before I can always play b3 and
after the capture take with the bishop
so just keep them the beef are closed I
can also think of playing is 6 cm this
is also quite quite nice rookie 6a
checking f5 very hard for him to cover
that and also putting more pressure on
g6 so that some at some time and an
exchange sacrifices may be possible but
ok let's get ahead with this the check
will bring the King back to g8 so how to
do it now look g5 is simple and good
just improving a bit more
okay yeah this yunji for him not sure
that it is the best move or anything but
rookie six is also possible I can just
play Quincy to back attack f5 now to see
how does he cover that I'm just cover
that I don't know f5 is just the tech
now baby you can summer operate with the
night XF form this tech check like King
f8 Bishop f5 night x f4 something funny
like that I'm just going to to cover
this make sure that this is not
happening ever at least I hope that it
is prevented preventing it ok and now
Bishop takes f5 next yeah he actually
after he opened the B file this also
rugby one being very interesting just
trying to invade on the queenside his
pieces are all stuck on the Kings side
they they cannot move ready okay here
this is a gamble that's a funny resource
Knight f3 here interesting ok um just
should be too maybe to keep it simple
hmm why it's a bit bit annoying the zoo
vet take let's check though if I take
can I take somehow with the pawn maybe
also what can I cover cover the rock
song they're probably not just cover
every there is still rupee one
this invading idea on the queenside
maybe you can play no G for him
94 to f6 okay so come on let's not use
any more time go for go for this Queen
side again is will be 70
okay can I take six and sacrifice
exchange on f5 and it's probably not bad
but also not not directly winning time
morning it wasn't it wasn't convincing I
mean he still check is still in the game
remarkable
they can just take a five I'm not
winning after that I don't think so okay
maybe takes Knight f7 there is Quincy a
check yes but yeah come on this is rook
f6 tripping the Queen rod don't tell me
there is something to save the Save the
Queen now nope check
check
28 seconds hmm check
check check check check
check he's got a check even less storm
check black results I wanted at the end
but it was it wasn't a really really
convincing performance out of all of
this out of this position is got 95
probably probably i missed something
along the way our group c 5 looks normal
ya hear the computer points or g fire I
had to mention the move but I didn't
want to place a such such violence stuff
1222 to win it yeah more conveniently
this is the other point is you need to
see this one with now f5 being a very
very big threat yeah the point being
that if he moves the king I have a five
point yes this is this is nice if he
moves the night now there is yeah
there's this idea this is why the Queen
must be on c1 ok but I played I played
it in a in a more strategical way ok
always plus 2 and here Queen 22 wins 22
wins yeah it looks good yeah covers Uruk
friends the night and night has nowhere
to go really yeah that's that's very
strong where's see going here can I can
take here let blacks falling apart ok
this is just this is also very nice but
now okay it's also about plus 21.7 1.4 I
don't ya nt okay blundered he blundered
the Queenie must take check play the
rook here and then we continue yeah it's
not ideal yeah if you look at how my
position was but okay at least it's
still a bit better for wine okay thanks
for watching